president dwight eisenhower was famous  for his productivity skills inspired by  him stephen covey in his book the seven  habits of highly effective people  introduced the eisenhower decision  matrix which is a tool that can help one  prioritize tasks based on four  possibilities urgent and important which  are tasks you will do immediately  important but not urgent which are tasks  you will schedule to do later  urgent but not important  tasks you will delegate to someone else  neither urgent nor important  tasks that you will eliminate i find the  eisenhower matrix extremely useful when  it comes to your daily task list once  you have listed all the tasks for the  day you can add them in the matrix based  on importance  the matrix will give you a more concrete  view of your tasks